all of a sudden when taylor swift's you
know on tv mouthing the words to your
songs and all of that and saying i wish
i could work with kendrick lamar and all
this
that shit's mind-blowing to a kid from
compton who who i mean no one was
banking on you uh your parents
were living where did they live before
they moved to california uh chicago
south side chicago chicago your dad was
your dad in a gang or something yeah
he was affiliated
so your dad's in the gang and your mom
uh they decide to move to compton right
and all they got is a garbage bag filled
with like two bags of clothing yeah and
they moved to compton and before you
were born
your dad worked at kfc right and your
mom worked at mcdonald's
how do you avoid getting into the gang
lifestyle in compton when your dad is
not telling you it's a bad thing
well he's actually telling me um but you
know what i'm saying
you got to find out for yourself
you know uh is that what he said do as i
say not as i do you know one of them
things but um he gave me the reality of
it you know but
as a man what he taught me as a
businessman you you have to go through
things you have to see for yourself you
can tell me everything in the world you
know but i'm still gonna go out there
and you know get my hands dirty um i
think it was really the act of my mother
being a dreamer you know they gave me
that duality that gave me that balance
did you feel unsafe to the point that
i'm surprised you were you were a
straight a student you were a good
student
you were a really good student i was a
good student and i think in in that
environment it's almost impossible to
keep your mind on studies when you're
sitting there and seeing people getting
shot in the street it's almost a miracle
if you can be a good student yeah
definitely and by good student i mean
straight a student that was decent i
wouldn't say straight a's
yeah i say straight
because i grew up in a pretty bad place
and if you excelled at school kids will
make fun of you yeah and which is
another crazy thing for learning right
yeah that is funny um
i know about that too because the thing
with me with school is
um
i was way uh more intelligent
than the actual
work i put out
because you keep it down i got to tone
it down i knew how far i can excel if i
put my focus and everything into it but
you know i was part of the cool kids and
you know you have your influence you
know you you want to do other things but
i knew how far i can go if i put
my work ethic into it so i took that
same mistake and i applied it with music
years later because i knew if i put my
focus in this you know i can excel this
guy top dog he has his own record
company right and he's the guy who
signed you yeah and you get upset when
he is compared to a suge knight
uh because you see a difference between
top dog and suge knight right yeah
definitely suge knight gets this rap
that he was you know gangster and you
know and maybe taking advantage of
people and all this and and and people
want to compare top dog to this guy yeah
i think because the the
physical image you know it's a big guy
yeah he has a red hat you know right and
you know of course you can't you can't
stop being affiliated but
we don't have the same tactics right not
at all you know we're we're professional
we're businessmen and we love what we do
and to risk that in any type of
violent nature
or
physical contact that's something we you
don't want to be a part of that we put
that up we put that behind us years ago
no when when top dog was in his roughest
days when he was a phil you know like
like the gangs
there's a story that goes and tell me
again because i find this mind-blowing
yeah your dad was working at kfc yep top
dog went into rob kfc
is this right
because you've written songs about this
yeah and he meets your father and top
dog's got a gun
your dad somehow thinks i don't want to
get into any [ __ ] with this guy i'm
going to charm him i'll even offer him
some free kfc
and maybe right and maybe he'll you know
won't get violent
and top dog liked your father true story
and did not rob the kfc because of your
dad
and now you're working with top dog
funny i like your ears right isn't that
weird that is the craziest story i've
ever ever heard it is the craziest story
have you sat with top dog and said what
the [ __ ] yeah man
it's my still my every time they come
around each other my pops in top dog
it's just
it's mind-blowing because they have to
bring it up they just sit and just look
at each other it's a trip
whoever knew that this little kid
that was in the back store while he was
flipping uh grease and and chicken wings
20 years later you know he'll be sitting
in the same studio you know and and
it always goes around to the fact that
the point is
okay what if you know he did take my
father's life oh i'd have been another
you know i probably wouldn't be in the
studio i wouldn't be right here with
y'all right now i'd be messed up because
it's a psychological thing we don't have
a father home especially growing up in
the environment we come from but
especially you know reading you know how
you add a conversion later on and became
more spiritual
with the life going like this
you can see
how you would become spiritual because
these are the kind of things that
usually go the wrong way yeah definitely
i can't take that for granted yeah